[Music]
Kendall and Kylie Jenner turned the
Vanity Fair Oscars party into a sister's
night out I'm obsessed with it Kendall
and Kylie hit up the who's who of
Hollywood bash following the 95th
Academy Awards you guys look so stunning
how's it feel to be here
that's Kylie in a shimmering custom
Maison margella gown complete with a
large bow and diamond earrings serving
bombshell glamor meanwhile Kendall was
giving goddess realness in a
form-fitting Jean-Paul Gautier dress
yeah
the two posted up on the blue carpet in
Beverly Hills and entered the event
holding hands
and once they were inside the Soiree
Kendall posted this clip of her little
sis cozying up with Gigi Hadid riding
alongside it simply hot it's everything
I could ever ask for and speaking of hot
Kendall and Gigi worked it for the
photogs too serving these epic snaps
give the fans exactly what they wanted
from us Kylie eventually opted for a
wardrobe change swapping out that
stunning black gown for this black and
tan striped number she showed off look
number two posing in the mirror with her
bff Stasi and capturing this selfie on
their luxury bus
we'll be there in five
minutes also in attendance Kendall and
Kylie's bestie Haley Bieber
[Music]
the model looked Chic in a custom black
Saint Laurent number featuring
asymmetric sleeves and a large shoulder
bow the outing marks her first public
appearance since her rumored Feud with
Selena Gomez earlier this month fans
speculated Haley and Kylie were bullying
Selena on Instagram after cell shared
this clip referencing her newly done
brows I accidentally laminated my brows
too much shortly after that Kylie posted
this snap writing this was an accident
over her brows and shared a close-up pic
of Haley's brows at the time Kylie
denied the post was about Selena calling
the whole thing silly Selena agreed and
said the drama was unnecessary but even
before all that some fans accused Haley
and Kendall Jenner of subtly dissing
Selena in a since deleted Tick Tock and
I'm not saying she deserved it but I'm
saying God's timing is always right Sal
later announced that she was taking some
time away from social media during a
tick tock live this is a little silly
and I'm 30 I'm too old for this so well
now sells back online and on Sunday she
shared a new trailer for season three of
her Hulu series only murders in the
building well you know who are we
without a homicide I think in general my
standards for humor and gentlemen
levar's been lifted pretty high working
with these two so it's been really fun
Paul Rudd and Meryl Streep joined the
cast and fans got their first look at
the A-list Editions
oh I'm sorry it's me isn't it
[Music]
thank you